football marriage two forces that have
been in opposition since the beginning
of time today we have a man Ned and his
wife Ariel and we're going to find out
do you know your favorite thing more
than you know your wife I hope he does
also be in trouble Paola
all right Ned we're gonna talk football
we're gonna talk to your wife you ready
for this yeah baby let's do this you
know football yes you know your wife
more Ariel how are you feeling this
thing he's gonna get more questions
right about me than he is about football
1 2 3 are you feeling ready yes oh yeah
it's like me up yeah question number one
Ned named five offensive positions in
the NFL quarterback running back wide
receiver often tackle tightest name of
five Ariel's favorite foods hmm let's
see
so olives breakfast burritos not on my
list but all that slide pasta salad one
more Ned remember this is the easiest
question that we have in this stack so
take your time Oh tiramisu
all right how many minutes are in a
football game uh 60 minutes how long
does it take Ariel to get ready in the
morning about 45 minutes 20 minutes
sorry we're gonna have to give you a big
red X on that one
all right Ned you've got 20 seconds name
as many starting quarterbacks in the NFL
as possible ready set go Lake bortles
Tom Brady
Russell Wilson Colin Kaepernick Phillip
Rivers Ryan Fitzpatrick Cam Newton
Matthew Stafford all right now you have
ten seconds name as many as Ariel's
bridal party as you can ready set go
Oh Danielle Carol Becca Annalise grace
five four five
Oh can't can't faze me Zack and cold as
ice net name the last two players
featured on the Madden NFL cover well
this past year was oil Beckham jr. and
the year before that it was Richard
Sherman but more accurately the entire
Seattle Seahawks defense described
Ariel's last profile picture on facebook
I remember the one when we first met
really well it was her and a giant dog
named George
a question not the question okay I think
it was one from our wedding when she was
like looking at me you're sweating Ned
you guys totally debugged my emotional
story about our first meeting
how many Super Bowl rings just Tom Brady
has two four or yes ah I hate Tom Brady
for Super Bowl roars how many raises
Arielle normally where to she wears her
engagement ring and her wedding ring how
many times have the Jaguars made the
playoffs that's hard 1996
so your answer I'm gonna go at six
that is impressive not only do you have
you got the number you got the years how
many times has Ariel been to a black tie
event
that's pretty tough we went to one
wedding this year I'll say seven what'd
I say that is correct
what year did the Jaguars join the NFL
I'm gonna go with 1985 because that's
one of the official announcement it was
what year did Ariel get her first
computer I will say 2003 that is correct
Oh Ned I am frustrated to report that
you do know your wife as well as you
know football so there you go turns out
Ned knows as much about his wife as he
does the NFL pretty adorable also a
little frustrating thanks for watching
do you know your partner better than
your favorite thing I'm Zach see you
next time
you